okay he is the host of msnbt's valve
sharing weekend weekend mornings Ali
balchees over here Holly great to see
you
and he's the former Democratic senator
from Alabama who was recently the White
House nomination advisor for legislative
affairs guiding the confirmation of
contentious Brown Jackson on the Supreme
Court Doug Jones
okay
so let's talk about Twitter and Free
Speech shall we and Elon Musk you know
we're all in the media of some way uh
the CEO of Twitter well maybe not any
longer but he was he said our role is
not to be bound by the First Amendment
now
let's just start with it is a private
company you can do whatever they want
right let's let's
that's a Dodge answer yeah what what
musk is saying is but it is de facto the
Town Square and some Sheriff could
should come in and say what good is the
first amendment if where the place where
people are really talking they can't
talk you think that's a valid argument
Doug knows more about the the legality
of it he's right and I think everybody
needs to get over the fact that the
First Amendment does not apply uh to
Twitter this is not government
censorship of anything I think what we
do have to worry about what Elon Musk
who's a really great thinker and is
really moving the needle on some
important things in life about electric
cars and about going to Mars I think
what he needs to think about is our
democracy which is struggling at the
moment relies upon an informed
electorate and that's always been a
problem for us historically but social
media is not helping us become a more
informed electorate so there's a
responsibility even by a private company
or private actors to say am I making a
bad situation worse and how do I get you
that town square that is so valuable
without wrecking society and I think
Twitter could have a serious
conversation with itself about that
asking Facebook well yeah yeah
no you know
I'm all for the First Amendment
everybody all Democrats are for the
First Amendment for goodness sakes
but Russian Bots do not have a First
Amendment privilege in this country or
on Twitter period in the discussion and
that's the biggest problem it's not it's
not it's that we can all agree on not
arguing let's just let's just at least
be who you really are yeah exactly right
but that's not really where the argument
is the argument to me is like has
Twitter failed
in setting themselves up in the past as
the judge of what can go out there and I
would say yes you have you failed
when you threw the New York Post off of
Twitter
for talking about Hunter Biden's emails
and it turned out that was a real story
right you failed when you said we
couldn't read about whether covet had
come from a lab
you failed
did you read about this Babylon bead you
know what the Babylon bee is
I didn't know this no it's like the
Christian version of The Onion
because everyone needs that
some people do I thought that was not
all you and me okay it says your trusted
source for Christian news and satire I
didn't know it was such a biggest
Christian sagile
I thought the religion itself was sad
that's me
I'm not everybody
okay I'm not everybody have a little
humility right so listen to this they
got flagged
for they posted a funny video this is
funny to them okay
sensitive content Twitter said in the
video they were making fun of Twitter
for being too sensitive this is so
through the Looking Glass and here's
what happens in the video this woman who
going into the Twitter building this is
you know parody this is what people do
on television have done forever okay
she's complaining to HR about how
sensitive Twitter is and the guy shows
her an ink lot and she keeps seeing
Hitler in all the ink plots
okay then she runs screaming out of the
building because she's this is sad this
is well within what satire has always
been and the fact that they flagged us
for being insensitive shows their
complete lack of self-awareness about
what their own problem is if that's
where the line is you have failed
Twitter you do need a new sheriff
you know look I I think people would
agree totally with that
um I I think what we're talking about
here though is trying to get back to
having those tweets or post or whatever
the hell you want to call it but the
fact of the matter is
insensitivity is one thing flat out
misinformation disinformation flat out
lies nothing fake news fake news is a
lie let's just let's put it out there
fake news is nothing but a lot and
things that incite violence things that
like that I think there is right well
that's that's in the First Amendment you
can't right you can't incite violence
and we're all right we're no one's
already so there's stuff that Twitter's
done that falls into that category and
we think that's okay I think the issue
is no one else is going to regulate them
because we've learned that we're not
anywhere close to being able to
understand this and regulate social
media so could these companies take some
responsibility and say imagine if we
were really that Town Square imagine if
we were this place where people with
differing opinions could have robust
discussions and there's a way they can
get there it's not what Elon Musk is
currently looking at and that worries me
a little bit but boy if he could do that
if we can create that real Town Square
what would it do for us you do it you
try and do it on your show right you you
battle people with different opinions
with respect and respect they're
pluralists right that's what that space
would do for democracy exactly